now that it's been three months since
apple launched the redesigned macbook
pros and the hype is settled down let's
get real is the 14-inch macbook pro
really worth a thousand dollars more
than the m1 macbook air or even more
than that since we constantly see it
discounted even as low as 850 dollars
links are down below in the description
by the way well today i'm going to
compare everything from a honest real
world perspective and keep it short and
sweet and answer the question once and
for all the m1 macbook air was my
favorite laptop before these new
machines hit the market even though i
had access to every macbook out there
this is the one that i kept wanting to
pick up and use there's just something
special about it that was hard to
explain but after the redesign launched
i have a much clearer picture the new
14-inch on the other hand is an absolute
killer machine it looks modern but also
retro at the same time bringing back
things that we've missed for a long time
while taking other things to levels that
no windows laptop can compete with
almost like when tesla launched their
new model s plaid which looks classic
but is also on another level compared to
everything else but just like that tesla
do people really need to have all of
that performance or does the model 3
macbook air make way more sense in the
real world since i mentioned design
let's start out with that the pro looks
bigger bulkier a bit meaner where the
air is thinner and sleeker in my opinion
the wet shape is iconic and even though
i didn't love it before because the pro
just looked more pro and i like that i
have to say that i prefer this wedge
shape just like i prefer the model three
with that as far as comfort the wet
shape does actually help with comfort as
a slim edge of the air doesn't cut into
your wrist like the thicker pro can and
even though the keyboard is arguably
better because it's an updated design
for most people it will make a
difference and if you type a lot you'll
probably prefer the air the same thing
goes as far as speakers the 14-inch pro
has the best speakers in any laptop of
this size go ahead and take a listen
[Applause]
[Music]
they are shockingly good with a huge
difference in base thanks to dedicated
woofers and if you are somebody that
will constantly be playing music at full
volume you will really enjoy them with
that said if i'm honest i don't think
that there's ever been a time where i
was sitting there wishing that the
speakers sounded better over louder with
the air they sound great and better than
most of laptops that it will end up
replacing of course the 14-inch brought
back the ports which your current laptop
may or may not have i love that magsafe
is back and we have hdmi and a card
reader and if yours has that now i would
kind of just track how often you use
those ports now for me most of the time
i just use usb type c and even though
dongle suck you just have to ask
yourself is it really worth spending
twice as much money to have them built
in instead of buying a cheap
multi-adapter
i've covered many of them in my top
macbook accessories video which i will
link to after the end of this video so
what is something that bugs me and that
is much better with the pro well that's
the webcam the 720p webcam on the
macbook air was an improvement over the
previous intel models thanks to better
processing but i was never really happy
with it because it kind of looked flat
kind of gray and then in darker
environments you get all this noise so i
always wanted it to be better that is
where the 14 inch macbook comes in with
its 1080p webcam that is much better in
low light situations thanks to its
faster aperture and then in the daytime
of course look sharper as well so
definitely if you care about that the 14
inch is better and with the webcams
let's talk about fans because previous
intel macbooks would spin up their fans
when they are working with video
so that would get annoying it would get
loud it'd be disruptive but the new
macbook air is fanless so you don't have
any of those issues now the pro does
have a fan but because of its efficiency
you never really hear it unless you're
pushing it to its limits so both of
these are pretty much silent now some
people may wonder as far as the
performance are you limited by not
having a fan i really push them to the
limits and yes the air can slow down but
it's not significant and not really a
big deal in the real world so what about
performance this might be the biggest
reason that you're considering the pro
instead of the air well i want to
challenge you a little bit and have you
take a second and ask yourself how much
performance do you really need to be
honest in the real world the air has
more than enough performance for almost
everybody because it smoked even the
expensive high-end 16-inch macbooks in
the past there are only a few people who
i would say that actually need the extra
oomph of the 14 inch and for a lot of
those people i would say you need even
more power you should spend even more
money than this base 2 000 model that
we're comparing to the air the extra cpu
performance cores do result in about 27
more multi-core performance which sounds
like a lot that it is but i have to be
honest and say that i have really never
noticed that in regular day-to-day tasks
that is due to the super fast single
core performance which is the same as
the 14-inch airs and that smokes pretty
much any other older laptop now for
tougher cpu tasks like logic music
production we see a similar difference
but for most people once you get to some
level performance that does what you
need you don't really notice anything
extra now for programming the difference
was about 32
and that can be significant if you're
constantly compiling code and that
performance difference will add up but
even the air was noticeably faster than
the previous errors that even cost more
money and were upgraded and of course
when you're actually writing code you're
not going to notice a difference and
somewhat the same thing happens for
photo editing where i didn't really
notice any difference at any of the
times that i edited photos all but one
time when i was working on a project of
over a thousand high-resolution photos
and really the limit was the eight
gigabytes of ram for that one and then
also when you were exporting those
photos it did take a while and i was
wishing that it was a little bit faster
so in that case if you're somebody
that's going to edit high amounts of
images make sure you at least upgrade to
16 gigs of ram and then see what else
might be worth it as far as the extras
with the 14 inch because then you might
want to upgrade but for most people even
doing photo editing the base model will
not be a limitation but where we start
to see a big difference is graphics
performance for gaming the pro gets
about double the frame rate as it should
having twice as many cores but nobody
really buys a mac for games at least you
definitely shouldn't when it comes to
using those graphics to speed up
productivity we have an overall
improvement of about 80
which is huge but once again a lot of
that is used for regular tasks and this
thing is just still very snappy it's
really only when you get to things like
3d rendering where everything will be
faster loading up your project
running shaders and then of course
rendering your project and you might
think that that is also the case for
video editing but this is where it can
be a little bit tricky if you're using
good software like final cut or resolve
and you're even working with 4k files
with minor effects you literally might
not notice any difference as long as the
graphics is powerful enough to handle
the workload even exporting will be
almost identical because of the same
rendering engines it's really only where
you hit this mac
with a lot of stuff like raw or heavy
effects or for example prores where you
start seeing a big difference because of
the dedicated pro res hardware and once
again that is where i would say you
should actually not get the base model
at least upgrade to the unbid version or
maybe even the m1 max because that will
make a much bigger difference the issue
is though that most people don't need
that amount of performance and people
really get stuck in the kind of thinking
where it's like what if i will need that
what if i'll need that a couple of years
from now and i would just say don't do
that that is marketing and that's how
you get stuck into spending double the
amount of money for a machine where
you're not going to use even half of
what it can offer and as far as future
proofing i think you're better off
buying a base model like this and then
if you need a performance you could sell
it and the resale is amazing on these
base lower price max and then at that
point you could buy whatever is the
latest and greatest and get a better
machine than what this 14-inch offers
today i think that is the better
financial decision and better overall
now the last things we have to cover are
battery life and the displays even
though the air has a smaller battery it
gets significantly better battery life
because of its more efficient processor
and graphics without having a fan and
because its display uses a lot less
power a huge part of the extra price tag
comes from the new mini led xdr display
that is capable of hitting up to 1600
nits instead of 400. now this was the
most attracting exciting thing for me
with these new macbooks other than the
performance but after three months of
use i have to say that for most regular
people it should not be as big of a deal
as apple would want you to think it is
yeah it is better especially if you
watch hdr movies in dark rooms and if
you are editing hdr photos or video you
do absolutely need that kind of a
display but the truth is that i mostly
use my mac with sdr content regular
websites in regular lighting and in
those scenarios it is very hard to tell
the difference side by side yes the 14
inch screen with that notch is
noticeably bigger and i do enjoy it but
unless you're gonna make the most out of
its capabilities it won't be as big of a
deal as apple made it seem at their
event and that actually paints a good
overall picture for the 14 inch macbook
pro how much of it will you make use of
and if you're only attracted to one or
two things say the ports and maybe the
better webcam i don't think that's
enough to justify the extra price point
if you see yourself looking at a macbook
air and saying i'm gonna upgrade the ram
and i also want that webcam i want
better speakers i will use the ports
consistently i need some of that extra
performance and all those extra benefits
start stacking up that's where i would
say you know what make the extra jump
and then spend the extra money but for
most people even though the pro is a
powerful class-leading machine the air
gets a job done and it does so very very
well
and it actually gets my topic in this
comparison for at least 90 to 95 of you
out there this is my recommendation
while it might seem a little bit
outdated it's not the latest and
greatest it is a phenomenal laptop and
for the price point it is the closest
thing to a perfect laptop that has ever
existed yes that is not good i'll go
ahead and link it down below you guys
don't have to buy through there but
there are some great deals on amazon and
also this one as well if you guys want
to pick it up and whichever one you
choose for uh choose to get check out
that video right over there i have the
best macbook accessories and you guys
can click above to help us reach our
goal of 1 million subscribers we
definitely appreciate it that's been max
and i will see you in the next video
[Music]